a movie about the ice queen my
ex-girlfriend said she'd be famous one
day dear we are frozen so frozen is a
new CGI Disney movie about the ice queen
really we all know the story of the ice
queen or if not you know the phrase what
an ice queen some chick who's being
really [ __ ] this is the story of the
ice queen but this movie explores the
concept and possibility of what if she
was just misunderstood which is really
intriguing that's a really cool route to
take on a story like this a props to
Disney for that revolves around two
sisters one of which has the ability to
freeze stuff like Bobby from x-men but
she can't really control it then she
becomes Queen and she freaks out and
freezes things everyone's like you're
terrible and so she goes up into her ice
palace and her sister goes on an
adventure to get her now we have a movie
a movie that really gets better the more
you think about it one it looks really
awesome when she's doing her ice thing
like icicles just going on the ground
the cameras following into jagged edges
they're all coming out of yet it's going
around the palace you're like this is
really epic stuff and the music is
really good like not just catchy good
hey I'm an Abba fan myself so you know I
like guilty-pleasure catchy songs no
this was like really emotional music and
the settings all epic also you're like
this yeah this is hitting yeah the
interesting thing is in movies like this
you're used to them being really funny
like Shrek or something like that if you
think back to Disney movies through that
I mean they have humor in them but
they're not comedies they really aren't
they're family movies they're family
movies that concentrate on the emotional
tone with the Disney Animation the good
ones anyway if it has a choice between a
joke or a touching moment it will take
the touching moment that's not a bad
thing and this movie does a good job at
that however it does have comic relief
in it I like the little snowman he was
awesome and this movie has more than a
couple of really good lessons in it I
wish this movie would have explored the
villain aspect more I can say this
because the movie doesn't end up this
way and I never thought the movie was
going to end up this way so I don't
think it's a spoiler I wanted the movie
to end on the road to where this ice
chick is now the villain of the story
and her sister has to fight her and kill
her and take her down and it's all crazy
and tragic I guess that's where Disney
draws the lines like tis too dark for
our family movies sorry man I'm always
opened is Niall cross that line one day
I guess today is not the day I thought
they might have been today stop how cool
would that have been though I mean she's
up in her ice castle she's all Arthas
and [ __ ] her sisters trying to find the
Lich Queen I don't see why just murdered
let's all ask for it wouldn't be more
tragic than Mufasa getting trampled by
the wildebeest I lived through that any
unfrozen was really good it was exciting
I liked the characters they were really
fun the movie slows down in a couple
parts you like alright you can pick up
the pace I was just thinking about it I
was like The Lion King I'm fully engaged
100% of the movie however in the end you
walk out going Disney still got it
that's not a bad thing I'm glad Disney
can still make good animation so I will
say frozen is worth buying on blu-ray
most overused rating of 2013 undeniably
but what can I say there's that good so
frozen have you seen it what did you
think about it you feel like Disney
still got it are you like no whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you